I had tuna net again and I have a
special request funk gained over he
request me to do a healthy dessert so
today I'm gonna make banana ice cream
and also can't tell the high screen but
we have a special gift today let's see
who's the special guess I'm gonna be
helping what we're gonna make today and
there's the the pie man yep banana ice
cream the ingredients that we will need
is banana banana of course I froze the
banana last or a couple days ago I could
the skin off put put it in the saran
wrap let it freeze overnight right now
we're gonna have Hayden open the banana
and put it in the blender yeah it is it
is cold right yeah we're gonna use these
ones to gonna make a lot more because we
have some guesses coming over tonight
yes what we have a party can you undo
this okay you won't come up no here you
go so why we chose banana because banana
contains vitamin b6 vitamin C magnesium
and fiber also biotin yummy nutritions
okay so you can just plant banana to
make the ice cream but today I'm going
to add some vanilla extract and the ND
cream we're gonna use let me see 2
teaspoon of vanilla extract oops I
overspill a little bit so we're going to
pour a little bit this here okay so 2
teaspoons okay so cream we're gonna use
scream yeah can you leave it okay let go
let go you hold this cup now I'm gonna
fit up quarter cup if we need more war a
little bit more cream yes okay pour it
in good job okay yeah yes and then I
find a lid you're still greater than
yeah just a little bit that's fine oh my
okay you want to turn it on no thank you
no he doesn't like this sound
because it's all frozen so you have to
shake it or use a spoon the Vitamix has
attachment I don't know what you call it
a stick whatever so I'll just push the
banana down oops Sammy yeah okay yes
extra just here now Piniella hmm tell me
this is um banana ice cream I'm gonna
put in the I'm gonna live in the freezer
for our guests to try tonight fool us
yeah I don't know so same thing for the
candle I froze it you can just freeze it
overnight but I froze it to three days
ago so you're done what hey then okay
here just quite a bit here you go but a
lot of cantaloupe I think this is
actually this is almost one whole
cantaloupe the nutrition is in
cantaloupe seventy-eight percent of
vitamin C and vitamin A has thirty
percent also have potassium and
magnesium and fiber okay so right now
we're gonna start blending the
cantaloupes
this is too much i'm going to take half
of the cantaloupe out here you go so i
just took half of the cantaloupe
so I'm gonna add back the rest of the
cantaloupe
test time oh my heart it's a workout you
know cooking's a workout okay okay let's
see how it tastes like no that's the
measuring spoon please see that you'd
smell squiddy nice very fresh you can
add cream or milk to your ice cream but
I decided not to because it's cream it's
not that's good so we're gonna have
Hayden do the test don't try it mmm
they're good daddy you want to try those
fun wanna try come over here and taste
come over here give them this spoon no
thanks hey don't want you did hey start
this is daddy's turn thank ya thank you
for watching if you liked this video
give it thumbs up and comment below and
this is for you innova Phylly bye hey
hey no no okay huh okay that's it okay
bye bye bye this I know can I eat it
with other people say back to the camera
or no ice cream say bye
hey Hayden start we have to wait my
daddy's telling me to do that that is
done he said he's doing this your face
is being blocked by no Dino I'm short
make sure to check out my nose letter ya
got 11 hi I'm Jason j-rod fonseka of
ra's online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring XD only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period